a supernatural Mystery Show looked dead
in the water until it released one of
its greatest outings a few short months
later and that's not the only series
that made us both cringe and cheer all
within one season friends ran on NBC for
10 seasons from 1994 to 2004 and it's
now regarded as one of the most iconic
sitcoms in TV history while it does have
some questionable moments it also has
very few truly unwatchable episodes but
one of those lesser outings is season
four's the one with the invitation which
has the lowest IMDb rating of any
friends episode it's been widely panned
since its Eclipse show rather than a
proper story the clips are all centered
around Ross and Rachel's relationship as
he struggles to decide whether to invite
her to his wedding with Emily meanwhile
season 4 also includes the one with the
embryos which follows pb's attempts to
be a surrogate mother for her brother as
she undergoes IVF treatment meanwhile
the rest of the gang takes part in a
trivia contest to see whether Chandler
and Joey know more about Rachel and
Monica or vice versa it's been so
acclaimed the TV Guide even ranked at
number 21 in its list of the top 100 TV
episodes of all time what is Chandler
Bing's job
Star Trek Deep Space 9 is perhaps the
most varied in terms of quality among
all Trek series over the course of its
seven season run it focused on the
titular space station that sits on a
wormhole many light years away from
Earth at the very edge of the Milky Way
galaxy the lowest rated episode
according to IMDb users is season 5's
let he who is without sin which sees the
crew Journey to the vacation planet of
ryza most of the complaints come from
the jarring story in what was supposed
to be a jovial and relaxing break along
with the way that dwarf acts out of
character compared to the rest of the
season on the other hand trials and
tribulations has established itself as
one of the greatest episodes in the
history of the entire franchise it sees
the crew travel back in time and
interact with the gang of the original
series from the episode The Trouble with
Tribbles along with the impressive
digital insertion technology the episode
also stands out for its clever story
beats and Sublime self-aware comedy Now
15 Seasons deep the effects and FXX
sitcom It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia
continues to crack up audiences with its
Twisted Adventures about awful people
running an Irish bar in the City of
Brotherly Love while it's never been a
huge rating set it's earned critical
Acclaim and a legion of devoted fans
however that doesn't mean that every
episode is a Surefire hit season 7's
Frank's brother is often listed among
the show's worst largely because it
focuses entirely on Danny DeVito's Frank
and his previously unseen brother Gino
and has a story that doesn't really go
anywhere but season 7 also features the
standout half hour chardie mcdennis the
game of games in which the gang plays a
hilarious party game that they've made
up that involves a series of strange
tasks and a bizarre set of rules simply
put the chaotic energy that always sunny
is famous for is taken to the limit in
this episode and so it comes to this
flip
uh
uh coin on the X-Files FBI agents box
Mulder and Dana Scully investigate a
series of paranormal events as they
become involved in a wider conspiracy
and arguably the best and worst episodes
of the show both aired in season three
teso dos bichos features very little of
Mulder and Scully which fans found
incoherent and confusing worst of all is
the fact that the big bad monster is
merely a group of feral cats making the
entire plot feel completely silly but
then there's Clyde bruckman's final
Repose which involves an insurance
salesman played by guest star Peter
Boyle who witnesses a series of brutal
murders this outing features plenty of
intelligent humor and an utterly
compelling Central mystery and then
there's Boyle's excellent performance as
well as a thoughtful look at some themes
that other less ambitious shows tend to
shy away from Lost was an absolute
phenomenon as it helped to launch a
golden age of TV when it debuted on ABC
in 2004. it follows a group of people
who survive a plane crash on a
mysterious island and band together as
they explore the supernatural goings-on
of their new home season 3 showcased
lost at its very best best and worst
with IMDB ratings indicating that
Stranger in a Strange Land is the series
at its lowest the plot sees Kate Carl
and Sawyer trying to make it back to the
beach as Jack attempts to rescue Juliet
from being killed with the help of Alex
critics were unimpressed with the
lackluster's story and the way it failed
to move the plot forward in any way but
a later episode that season set a new
bar the two-part season finale Through
the Looking Glass is an edge of your
seat Thrill Ride that packs an emotional
punch and maintains a constant sense of
suspenseful excitement there's even a
brilliant twist at the very end that
completely changed the game for lost
going forward we have to go back
before the launch of the dceu or
Christopher Nolan's Dark Knight trilogy
the best adaptation of the Caped
Crusader was undoubtedly Batman the
Animated Series it detailed The
Adventures of Batman and Gotham City as
he fought a variety of villains the show
earned critical Acclaim and a passionate
fan base but it did have a handful of
episodes that didn't quite reach the
heights of the rest of the series season
ones I've got Batman in my basement
represents the bottom of the barrel as
it follows two young detectives who
inadvertently end up rescuing Batman
through a series of outlandish events
the amateurish way that the penguin is
constantly outsmarted and the general
silliness of the plot ensure that this
episode can never be considered a
classic say Batman you wouldn't be
single would you but the first season
also delivered almost got him which sees
the Joker Two-Face Killer Croc Poison
Ivy and the Penguin discussing The Times
They Came closest to finally defeating
Batman once and for all it's an
interesting look at these villains
containing lots of witty humor and some
great action sequences the plot twist at
the end is also entirely unexpected and
brings a satisfying conclusion to a
nearly perfect installment from the
creative mind of Larry David HBO's Curb
Your Enthusiasm features the comedian
playing a lightly fictionalized version
of himself having retired from writing
television he gets into a constant
stream of trouble by bumping up against
social norms and disregarding what
others think while curb is steadily
delivered laughs for Seven Seasons there
are several episodes that have missed
the mark especially season 2's the
acupuncturist suffering from neck pain
Larry makes a bet that he won't be able
to ease his suffering the episode has
proved unpopular with fans due to its
lack of funny moments and important
events in contrast the doll represents
curb at its very best everything works
beautifully in this episode from the
uncomfortable comedy to the clever story
that comes to an enormously satisfying
conclusion the brilliant scene where
Susie berates Larry as he tries to
replace a doll's head that he cut the
hair off of is an undeniable series
highlight the kid is home hysterical
because her doll Judy has been
decapitated
Twin Peaks was widely acclaimed when it
debuted on ABC in 1990 and has since
cemented its place as one of the best TV
shows of all time created by David Lynch
and Mark Frost it follows FBI agent Dale
Cooper and Sheriff Harry S Truman's
investigation into the murder of
teenager Laura Palmer in the fictional
Town of Twin Peaks Washington even the
worst episode of Twin Peaks has a
respectable IMDb DB rating of 7.2 while
there are some important plot points in
season 2's slaves and Masters it also
features the outlandish Benjamin horn
section in which the character has a
mental breakdown and reenacts the Civil
War simply but it's one of the most
confusing moments in the entire show
meanwhile lonely Souls officially titled
episode 14 makes a strong case for
itself as the absolute best of Twin
Peaks not only does it finally reveal
exactly who killed Laura Palmer bringing
some clarity to the case that has been
the center of the show since the pilot
it also includes a satisfying twist and
answers to other long-standing questions
The Big Bang Theory is one of the most
successful sitcoms of the 21st century
the first season arrived on CBS in 2007
and the show quickly became a mega hit
charting the lives of four socially
awkward men as well as Cheesecake
Factory server Penny it ran for a total
of 12 Seasons until its conclusion in
2019. it won numerous Awards made stars
of its cast members and led to the
spin-off prequel series young Sheldon
but any show that runs that long
inevitably has a few missteps and for
Big Bang the worst of the worst could
very well be season 12's the inspiration
deprivation it's one of just seven
episodes that has an IMDb rating of less
than 7 out of 10 like many outings of
the final season it's a disappointing
entry that acts as a filler episode
where nothing much happens other than
rehashed jokes about Howard and
Bernadette's relationship on the other
hand the greatest episode of The Big
Bang Theory also arrived in season 12 in
the form of the series finale entitled
the Stockholm syndrome packed with
emotional payoffs such as Sheldon and
Amy receiving their Nobel prizes and
Penny and Leonard finding out that
they're expecting it provided a
satisfying way for the show to end while
tying up pretty much every loose end in
my way
I love you all
Buffy the Vampire Slayer debuted in 1997
and ran on the WB for Five Seasons
before heading to UPN for its final two
seasons thereby airing on both
forerunners of the CW its success
launched Sarah Michelle Geller's career
as a leading actor and led to the
spin-off series Angel the irresistible
premise is that high school student
Buffy Summers hunts down vampires and
other evil mythical creatures with her
enhanced fighting skills while Buffy is
beloved by its Legion of fans it also
had its notorious moments and there's
plenty to dislike in season 4's beer bad
it introduces viewers to the revolting
werewolf Veruca and for most of the
episode Buffy silks about Parker and his
betrayal after it's discover that he's
working with the vampires the biggest
letdown is the fact that the whole point
of the episode appears to be nothing
more than a condescending message for
college students to not drink beer
freshman girl not able to hold the beer
shouldn't have it get into trouble but
the fourth season more than made up for
that misstep with a classic episode hush
which sees a new group of ghouls that
silence the town and kill the residents
by cutting out their hearts this force
is Buffy and her allies to communicate
without being able to speak thus
creating a compelling shift in their
Dynamics as they adjust to the new
circumstances
despite Thriller Homeland focuses on CIA
agent Carrie Matheson as she
investigates former prisoner of war
Nicholas Brody and various other plots
against the United States it ran on
Showtime for eight seasons from 2011
until 2020. it went over plenty of fans
and earned multiple Awards but it also
had plenty of frustrating episodes the
worst is almost certainly long time
coming the season 4 finale that didn't
really have any interesting story twists
and lacked the bombastic action of
previous finales many fans also
complained that long time coming seemed
more like a filler episode that didn't
properly address what had happened
throughout the rest of the season but
just a few episodes before that there's
something else going on got every single
viewer on the edge of their seats as
they nervously watched a prisoner
exchange to release Saul from a group of
terrorists a slow and methodical episode
it's nevertheless a nerve-wracking watch
that twists in unexpected ways to keep
the drama at a high level throughout TV
Guide named it not just one of the best
episodes of Homeland but also among the
very best episodes of any show of 2014.